à marseille les profanateurs du
cimetière juif de carpentras ont entendu
aujourd'hui les différents avocats de la
partie civile les mettre en accusation
mais aussi ceux qui par leur discours
ont inspiré leur geste reportage
dominique verdeilhan philippe chasselas
front commun du côté des avocats des
victimes ce n'est plus le procès de
quatre profanateurs mais celui d'un
cinquième homme jean marie le pen le
procès d'une idéologie celle de
l'extrême droite les prévenus l'ont
admis certes le troisième reich les
fascinait mais le discours du front
national les a séduit presque conforté
dans la haine de l'autre vous êtes les
rejetons de l'open le boutiquier de
l'immonde lance un premier avocat vous
êtes les instruments des partis
fascistes enchaîne un second vous êtes
passés de la théorie à la pratique
est incontestablement
c'est la génération le pen sont ceux qui
à un moment donné peignant dans ce
discours influencé par celui ci pense on
peut on peut tout dire et si on peut
tout dire on peut tout faire devant le
risque d'une banalisation du discours
devant la crainte de voir l'histoire se
répéter les avocats des parties civiles
veulent donner à ce procès une valeur
pédagogique
on a indiqué à ces gens que le juif
était différent que le gif était
nuisible pour la société française et
c'est ce qui les a motivés et c'est la
raison pour laquelle ce procès doit être
pédagogique pour montrer que cela n'est
que fadaises à la veille des
réquisitions les caps profanateurs sont
passés au second plan alors soulignant
le côté dérisoire de la peine encourue
deux ans de prison au maximum les
victimes ne parlent plus de sanctions
mais de leçon